donc moi ça n'atteignait que je propose
dans le cadre des archives
départementales de la réunion son
atelier autour de la découverte des
instruments du maloya à savoir le roulèr
le kayamb le piqueur et le sati
également et donc moi je propose des
petits des petites séquences où les les
enfants et les parents aussi sont là
pour apprendre et rythme de base du
maloya et pour chanter un petit peu donc
voilà c'est un petit moment d'initiation
en espérant les retrouver plus tard
excellent plat et surtout
oui c'était très bien puisque au moins
ça nous apprend à faire de la musique
est ancrée d'intéressant j'ai plus cher
de la nutrition
les désastres humains et aussi à leurs
sonorités dernier une table
le kayamb triangle le holà je
connaissais les chansons déjà mais
c'était vraiment bien
je verrai ça marchait sur le bord avec
un bâton presque 1 bat avec puisqu'on
bat là on voyait qu'on avait une qui se
débrouillait bien les autres copies et
entre guillemets donc sur ces c'est
toujours intéressant
hamon n'est pas là non plus pour faire
de la formation musicale où l'impôt
l'anc leur donner envie leur faire
plaisir avant les fêtes